إنها ليست وظيفتي التي أشاهدها وأنت تعلم أنني
أشاهد المعركة السياسية ، فليس من
واجبي الانحياز إلى جانب ، لذا
لن أخوض في قضايا تتعلق بالسياسة ، لكن قصتك الشخصية
مقنعة بشكل لا يصدق ،
وحاول الرئيس إثارة قضية قولك هذا.
كنت جزءًا من المشكلة التي لم تكن
تنتمي إليها هنا ،
حيث لا يجب أن تفوز في
انتخابك لأنك كنت جزءًا من المشكلة التي
ذكرتها السناتور هاريس الليلة
الماضية سيكون لأمريكا أول نائب
رئيس لها ، وهي أول امرأة
ملونة نائبة للرئيس.  شخص ما عائلته
لديها خلفية متنوعة بشكل لا يصدق ،
كيف ترى هذه اللحظة التي ذكرت فيها
التخلص من ترامب كأولوية رقم واحد
ولكننا نحصل أيضًا على التاريخ
في الجناح الغربي كيف ترى
اللحظة
آه إنها لحظة مفعمة بالأمل.  أعني أنني
شاهدتها وهي
تأتي
لتمشي على تلك المنصة لإلقاء خطاب لها
مع ابنتي الصغيرة التي
تبلغ من العمر ثماني سنوات
وأول ما قاله إلواد لي
كان هذا الشخص الذي يشبهني
ماما
وأنت تعلم أنه لا يمكننا إغفال
حقيقة أنك تعرف أن
التمثيل قوي
أه أنها سمحت الآن
للعديد من الفتيات الصغيرات ليس فقط في
بلدنا ولكن في جميع أنحاء العالم
أن يروا أنفسهم آه كشخص
يمكن أن تصعد إلى أحد أعلى
المناصب في أمتنا ،
وكما قالت أن أي شيء يمكن أن يكون
ممكنًا إذا كنت على استعداد للعمل من
أجله ،
أعني أنني أتذكر في عام 2018 ، كان الكثير من
الناس يأملون لأن الكثير منا جلب
التنوع
إلى  منزل أتذكر أنني كنت متفائلة
عندما
فازت بسباق مجلس الشيوخ وأعتقد
أنك تعلم في وقت رأينا فيه جميعًا
ما فعله ظلام ترامب
بأمتنا وفقدان الأمل
والدمار والإذلال الذي شعر به الكثير منا
أن يكون هناك شخص مثله
يمثلنا كرئيس لنا ، ليصبح لدينا الآن
أشخاص متفائلون يتحدثون
عن
التفاؤل الذين سيحكمون
باحترام ولياقة
، والرحمة والتعاطف
هو حقًا مثال على نوع
أمريكا التي يريدها والدي  د
لإحضارتي إلى أمريكا التي نريد جميعًا
أن نربيها لأطفالنا